rod i want to start with this monday
night football game this is an
unbelievable monday night game it was
back and forth to back and forth first
half you sort of felt like it was gonna
be bills all the way and it comes all
the way down to that fourth down play
that we just saw
start me with the decision what do you
think of the decision to go for it there
where you could have tied up the game
with 22 seconds left did you like it and
the play call as well what'd you see are
you are you kidding me you're gonna
actually ask me that question and you
know how much of a fan i am of josh
allen the guy's 245 pounds he slipped he
slipped 99 percent of the time he would
have made that i thought it was a good
aggressive call
i thought coach showed a lot of
confidence in his offense and obviously
man josh he has to do a better job of
staying up and getting that first down
but i i definitely didn't have any
problems with the call what about you
so i like the decision to go try to win
it and that's that's basically what
you're doing you're saying forget over
time we just believe in this monster
that we have playing quarterback that
he's going to go get it i don't love the
play call though earlier in the game as
well i saw josh allen struggle with the
quarterback sneak with his body with his
power with him being able to get
downhill and be a freight train i prefer
him out of the shotgun running
quarterback power as opposed to being a
tall guy down around the line of
scrimmage trying to create leverage
which he doesn't have naturally i don't
view him as a tom brady type who's great
at quarterback sneaks so i disagree with
the sneak call i like that they're being
aggressive and going with it but give
them a chance to run quarterback power
and go run somebody over don't do
quarterback sneak man
it was they had they needed one yard and
if we could run that clip back producer
i want you to look at the left tackle
dion dawkins he absolutely got destroyed
on the play he got pushed back
and what can he do look at the left
tackle watch the left tackle i want you
to watch the left tackle
what can josh do when your left tackle
is getting totally annihilated like that
what can he do so that's why i say i
really didn't have a a problem with the
actual call but these guys have to come
ready to play and deion dawkins did not
want it he did not want it and look at
him he's on his back he's a 300 pounder
it's the most critical play of the game
and he had a mental lapse and he got
physically handled so i didn't have a
problem with it but he has to do his job
i thought that happened a lot in this
game tennessee just played so hard up
front they got that verbal attitude
about them but i thought there was a lot
of moments where you just saw
tennessee's defensive front bullying the
offensive line of buffalo we haven't
really seen that happen much this year
but in one of the biggest moments of the
game like you just pointed out it looked
like tennessee was thinking quarterback
sneak quarterback sneak they reacted
just like that getting that initial push
which blew up to play i want to hear
from coach mcdermott on the decision to
go for it and the call that ensued here
was the head coach on a tough one that
resulted in a loss
far from from winning the game
and i owe that to my players and
you know i believe in my players i
believe in our quarterback um
so
i trust my guys
obviously we didn't get it done in this
case um but i trust my players
didn't work out in our favor obviously
didn't have the greatest footing
um
it happens
game of inches
you know the gate the the play before
was pretty close too um
didn't turn out in our favor today you
know felt
you know hey if we're that far from
potentially winning the game right there
was the best thing we could do we hadn't
stopped him on defense
for for
a number of drives there in the second
half really so
but again felt like we could go and win
the game right there and uh obviously
didn't get it done
i really do respect the call and i
respect the belief that he has in josh
allen and he's had that belief the whole
year long but if you go back to the
previous play and josh like hurdling
doing some crazy stuff basically almost
got the first down on his own i just am
thinking get away from that that mess
there in the middle that tennessee's so
great at creating and just do sort of a
quarterback bootleg and just have him
sort like this where he could throw he
could run and just let him go hammer
that ball in on the outside this is that
previous play this to me is where josh
is is most dangerous as a runner on db's
he was darn close though i mean look at
the magic he can create on the outside i
don't know why you wouldn't want him
operating
quarterback jumping over like that
you don't want your quarterback doing
that jack come on bro you don't want him
out there like that in open space with
the dangers out there a quarterback
sneak look at tom brady he's not even
half the size of this kid and tom brady
is the best in the probably in the
history of the national football league
with quarterback sneaks this is a
situation where the coach
hey he trusted his players they went out
and they flat out just didn't execute
and like he said if they're this close
from winning the game he has to go for
it i thought it was a smart call but i
do want to change the focus a little bit
and give tennessee titans defense props
they set the tone early in the game when
they held buffalo to those first two
drives to field goals i thought that
gave them a lot of confidence and it
really
set the tone early i thought daniko
autry i thought he had a tip which led
to her inner interception david long was
all over the field harold um landry he
played outstanding so i thought that
mike vrabel did an excellent job just
recreating that defense and having those
guys play hard and play with a lot of
passion
tennessee's just one of those teams that
have some massive human beings i mean
they just have some huge guys and i
think it's intentional i think this is
the way that brave was built this team
and finally they're healthy and they're
all in the field at the same time you
see it with the defensive side but you
also see it with aj brown julio jones
derek henry that's a lot for these
safeties in these corners to have to
deal with all game long and you just see
it wear on people it just wears them out
and when you look at derek henry's night
143 rushing yards he had
126 of those after first contact 126
after contact so that's what derek henry
does he just just body blow body bow
body body blow that's the word i'm
looking for and then it's just the
haymaker over the top and that usually
comes in the fourth quarter just like it
did against buffalo on monday night
[Music]
yeah absolutely and just think from a
defensive standpoint you know you come
out and you stop derrick henry three or
four or five straight times you're
pumped off you go on the sideline then
all of a sudden he rips off one for 25
yards then all of a sudden he rips off
one for 50. then he all of a sudden he
rips off one for 70.
that's the danger of this offense
because that's exactly what they do they
physically wear you down you get
confidence thinking okay we're going to
get derek henry before he gets started
and then he comes and he splits my pro
bowl safety and he goes and nobody can
can um catch them this guy is huge 300
um 63 235 40 pounds and he runs four
four four three i mean this is just
ridiculous and that's
that's what they're gonna have to do
they're gonna have to lead him right
into the playoffs ride him right into
the playoffs and nobody's even talking
about their offense this offense hasn't
even really practiced together you think
about julio jones aj brown ryan
tannehill they really haven't been able
to develop that chemistry and the way
you develop that chemistry is by
practicing together julio jones didn't
practice a lot when he was here in
atlanta and since he's been in tennessee
he doesn't practice very often so i
expect if he's healthy and if he can
practice that their their continuity and
their chemistry will only continue to
get better and this offense will
definitely be a lot more dangerous
and i think tannehill is sort of the
forgotten man he's like one of the most
forgotten quarterbacks in the whole nfl
you know what i mean like he doesn't get
the respect because derek henry is such
the superstar and the whole offense goes
through him but he does such a beautiful
job in my opinion of playing robin to
that batman and just being willing to go
okay i'm not going to lose the game i'm
not gonna have that big turnover but he
does more than game manage i think he
makes enough plays on the outside he
makes enough scrambles with his legs
where he'll go get that big first down
and he has a little attitude a little
energy about him when he does it that i
think raises the whole team so tannehill
to me is one of the more disrespected
quarterbacks in the league just because
of how great their running game is but
he week after week is an efficient
passer that gives you a chance to win
games and in my opinion tannehill is a
reason why this is one of the teams at
the top of the afc they just proved it
they're up there with the ravens they're
up there with the chargers they're up
there with the buffalo bills they are
among the best in the afc because
tannehill routinely gives them a chance
with the super heroics that you have
happening with derek henry right behind
him
yeah no doubt man tany hill's a tough
dude but i got to give a lot of props to
another tough guy aj brown i mean the
way he was sick and he talked about food
poisoning jack if you ever had food
poisoning i'm sure you have cause i've
had it it is no joking to try to play
exactly and try to play football with
food poisoning and he came up with some
big plays and just think about it when
your teammates know that you're sick and
that you're going out there sacrificing
they draw strength from that they look
at you say man this guy's sick you know
what
let's let's do this so your teammates
rallied behind you and i thought he
showed a tremendous amount of toughness
and and really mental toughness to get
through the game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports